okay so these are the things that I
don't think will work okay
so now when I first got into the red
pill space you know my actual first
thought was I didn't know why men didn't
want to get
married this was a little bit foreign to
me because most people in my family were
married if they did divorce people got
remarried in like know extended family
whatever marriage was kind of the
norm
so you know when I first got into the
red pill space this this was a confusion
to me and I want to show you
guys how I changed my
mind I started interviewing guys about
their divorce experience I'm going to
show you guys one now this is a guy
who had a
woman turn his whole entire family
against him he had two kids he hasn't
seen I think it was two I forget
sometimes I get the guys confused he
basically gets married right he wants to
I mean does he look like an evil monster
to
you does he look like this
evil awful
guy and and you can you could be the
judge Maybe I'm Wrong maybe he's just
lying
you know and this is him talking about
his
experience um getting married and
divorced okay yeah Bob the trucker let's
call them you to see their your side
they every time I ask them that I need
you to support me here I stopped
communication with the exh because
obviously that plays into her Court they
all said no we're going to cont continue
contacting her because then she what she
was doing she was carrying on
communication with my family MH and I go
she said this so so she alienated him
from him his entire
family his entire family because she
told his entire family he was an abuser
all this stuff about him she said this
for I don't
know um so what would she tell your
family would she say that you abused her
yes so I was abusive and all the same
thing I was financially abusive um oh so
she's basically started brainwashing
your family that's the best way of
explain it yes
thinking that and like because she's a
woman wait did you guys say the volume
the volume needs to go up
okay okay I think it's this which one is
it
blessing okay I'm gonna I'm gonna test
one I think it might be this no that's
not it okay this one I'm going to try it
like kind of crying wolf in a way is
this better and um
your mother your sister your father and
your cousins okay
and um and then basically she would use
them to get you to break the order yeah
so like she would make it so you didn't
see your son through okay the volume's
low how do I okay I gotta remember which
one this
is okay let me let me text blessing
sorry you expected this all right all
right
um
[Music]
wait which one is it I'm
sorry
four your family because she made your
mother the primary oh it's there like
care like person okay I'm sorry guys
we're going to started
over okay but basically guys I would do
interview after interview after
interview it would be the same stories
and I'm I'm going to show you okay
sorry on the keyboard
okay the volume's on here that plays
into her cult now can you hear they all
said no we're going to cont continue
contacting her cuz then she what she was
doing this look was great on me I served
I served in Orange sorry sorry she was
carrying on communication with my family
and I got she said this what she saying
this for I don't
know um so what would she tell your
family would she say that you abused her
yes so I was abusive and all the same
thing I was financially abusive um oh so
she basically started brainwashing your
family that's the best way of explaining
it yes into thinking that and like
because she's a woman basically she she
was like kind of crying wolf in a way
exactly and um your mother your sister
your father and your cousins okay
and um and then basically she would use
them to get you to break the order yeah
so like she would make it so you didn't
see your son through your family because
she made your mother the
primary like care like person so your
mom had to pick up your son and she was
speaking to your mom and making it so
and then she could go to court and say
you broke the order correct it was it
was my mother who broke the order if you
imagine if that now happens that shows a
dysfunctional
family oh
okay and that's the route she was going
there so then you go to the second court
date and what happens um uh she then
said to me so on the first few all right
you guys are saying it's too loud
now um let me turn it down a
four okay let me
put um days I have my son and weekends
one weend ask for can you bring some
toys with with him cuz I had seen him
for 5 months I didn't know what his toy
taste had changed you know I asked for
clothes I asked for Wellies well well
boots and asked him for a jacket she put
that against me in the courtroom said to
me that was demanding
Behavior wow that's the worst she could
put against me at that point demanding
Behavior demanding Behavior okay and I
had to discuss to the court so out of
those three obviously the court
Judiciary System has to go has to choose
a topic I had to explain to the court
why I asked for toys to accompany my
son um which was I just wanted to
support him I didn't know the toys I had
were now too young for him um I wanted
to be able to know roughly what his
taste were make it comfortable for him
and then I'd be able to go toys
us afterwards you know um in fact I
didn't even know what his nappy size was
I didn't know what his clothes size was
when I picked him up it was just
literally in his clothes in his jacket
and a toy in his hand and that was
it he was two and a half then uh yes he
would have been two and a half yes okay
so then what did the court what did the
court tell you so the court asked me to
explain why I asked for toys mhm so I
went into why explain why I asked for
toys
um uh and then they said
um due to the breakages in the course
order um to of disagreements going
on um they only gave me then once a
fortnite and that was it now why I had
so once every other week they do I also
had to go in so this guy wants to be a
traditional involved
father this woman turned his entire
family against him he gets to see his
son twice a
month guys this is not uncommon I'm G to
keep going hold on the advice was to go
in to ask for that as well because
otherwise I could get nothing because of
because leading up to the so it was a
Christmas
period um I was supposed to see him
Christmas Day it all broke down the
night
before um and then my mother started to
try and reduce the amount of contact I
was getting um she she canceled all
contact which obviously played into my
ex's hands and I didn't see my son for
another 2 and a half months so you saw
him once at two when he was 2 and a half
years old and then you didn't see him I
saw him for about 8 to nine
weeks okay and then so it was like four
months and mind you this costs men like
20 grand a lot of the time I think
that's the average cost 20 grand to get
to see their son every other
week this is
hell this is hell to men okay and if you
guys pull up this playlist called the
sitdown you'll see some of the other
interviews I've done like I I don't want
to just because it's kind of long this
guy um he the government took his
teenage daughters
away um I I think it was this
one I mean he told me he was on the
verge of suicide
um there there was another guy who I
think it was him he his kids
lived a mile from him and he hadn't seen
them in two years and so you know I
would just listen to like story after
story after story after Story Volume my
volume's
slow can you can you guys hear me okay
well and you know it's like guys I I
can't ignore this
stuff I mean even let's say there's a
10% chance this happened to you which I
mean divorce is 50% it's not 10 but
let's say it's
10 I mean would you sign up for a 10%
chance they destroy your entire
reputation
steal your
children take half of your assets uh one
of the guys I interviewed was literally
homeless because he couldn't afford
child support because he lost his job
because of the stress of
everything okay
so things okay so do I want to go with
things that I think okay so
if you're a trucker I want I want us to
like put us in the the mind of a trucker
in Missouri making $55,000 a year and he
thinks I want a wife and kids I want to
do the traditionalism thing how does he
get there and guys this is just my point
of view you can take it or leave
it the women are the ones begging for
the premarital sex okay one the majority
women that's what they want okay but he
says I I want a wife and kids is it
probable for him to wait for a virgin
chick I would argue
no and women women typically want a guy
and I'm not saying this is what guys
should do or shouldn't do I'm I'm trying
to
explain I'm trying to explain why men
get to this conclusion
from my from my point of view okay women
want a guy with more
experience
okay and he doesn't want to get you know
how is he supposed to know the
difference between a good woman and a
bad
woman the only way he could do that is
to get experience with
women so I don't really blame men for
choosing to sleep around I'm not saying
they should I'm not saying it's good
okay I'm saying I don't really blame
them if they get to that
conclusion
okay
um is it a good idea for a guy to wait
for a non virgin does that really make
sense is it a good idea for a guy to
have no experience with women and sign
up for a
contract that could take away his
reputation his
children and
his like everything really from a guy
now I again I'm not saying what he
should do but I can kind of understand
you
know why men get to that conclusion